Mike Pereira Fox Sports NFL rules
analyst former vice-president of
officiating Mike joins us this morning
hi Mike how are you I'm good dan how are
you I'm doing okay is there anything to
talk about
only the fact that I at least have
another job for a year
it's the kind of yesterday keeps me
employed aren't you glad that you're not
the vice president of officiating
anymore I guess
that's much my favorite word is okay
what did you see with the Jesse James
catch non catch well I saw it was
incomplete immediately when I saw the
first replay we were all sitting in here
in the studios in Los Angeles and myself
Dean Blandino on our staff and we saw
the first replay we said incomplete and
we knew it's just gonna be a matter of
time before replay actually initiated
the review and then made the decision
here's the notion and I've been
obviously following social media and
listen to what people are saying about
me but all of the reasons that people
are using to say it is a catch that the
knee was down that he turned upfield
that he lunged a for a touchdown that he
reached for a touchdown mm-hmm all of
those are out the window all of those
get trumped by going to the ground so
you have to hold when you're going to
the ground you can turn upfield you can
do all that stuff but as with Dez Brian
a couple years ago you must hold on to
the ball and so we knew immediately that
it was gonna be reversed to incomplete
okay but let me look at this step by
step in my opinion catch the ball now
you make a football move your knee goes
down now I thought when your knee goes
down you have the ball you make a
football move now it becomes a fumble he
did break the plane the ball bobbled
after his elbow hit the ground so what
what am I missing in that equation with
knee going to the ground have the ball
extending to go over the goal line what
what you're missing here is a couple of
things number of one the notion of going
to the ground so it Trump's all that
number two is you are not a runner you
have not become a runner because you
have not completed the process of the
catch everything basically that you're
talking about and every
buddy else is talking about when it
comes to making a football move all
applies to the receiver who is upright
on his feet he gets control two feet
down turns up field now he's hit and the
ball comes loose there you have a
catching fumble because he completed the
three elements but the three elements
only apply to that receiver that's on
his feet it does not apply to the runner
going to ever the receiver going to the
ground to attempt to complete the
process of the catch and that's what
makes it difficult and I grant you that
we have made it difficult for people to
understand I say we but we have made it
difficult for people to understand what
is a catch but if you look at that first
in real-time the live coverage that CBS
had the one thing you conclude
immediately is that James is going to
count so you know then at that point
forget me forget steps forget lunge
forget everything the ground trumps
everything and so you have to survive
the ground and we had we have a couple
of different situations for that happen
yesterday we're ruling on the field was
catch reverse to instant instant replay
to incomplete on the same criteria and I
know it's tough but that is the rule
that's what competition the competition
committee has put in place and that's
where replay is somebody asked me this
morning it was an interesting question
back in your days when you were on the
field would that have been a touchdown
and the answer is yes and the reason the
reason that it is is because there was
no instant replay so instant replay has
gotten into this with this technology
and dissected everything to see the ball
just touching the ground and to see the
laces flip over and and reverses it to
incomplete but that was the right ruling
can the ground caused a fumble sure but
you're a runner okay you're a runner now
the ground can cause a fumble if you're
not touched by a defender and then the
ground can talk that caused a fumble if
you're touched then the ground cannot
but again your runner you've two
different you you don't become a runner
until you've completed the process of
mic doesn't this go back to that stupid
Calvin Johnson ruling of completing the
process and the NFL is holding on for
dear life about completing the process
yeah it does but it really goes back
further than that to Burt Emmanuel back
in the playoffs in 99 I think it was
that's where that's where we flipped it
and said look at you know the the fact
that the ball touches the ground
shouldn't take away a great catch if in
fact you hold on the ball so we made
that change then and maybe we're
suffering the conferring the
consequences of it now but you know
people say to me when you have a play
that you know looks to the fifty guys in
the bar that it's a catch and/or a
touchdown or whatever then it ought to
be but here's the here's the kicker to
me and let's catch no catch thing I'm
just not sure that replay belongs in
this because replay then really dissect
it and that's where replay is now they
dissect it through a fray by frame by
frame thing and look and looks at it and
finds a way to overturn it the ruling on
the field which to the officials looks
like a touchdown yeah and that's why
it's ruled that way but that's where we
are today would you get rid of the rule
I'm not sure that I would get rid of the
rule I mean you have to have some
guidelines look at when when the
competition committee talked about this
in terms of you know should going to the
ground should a reach should a lunge
should a turn up field complete the
process of they catch going to the
ground I think the committee was
concerned rightfully so is you're gonna
make you're gonna bring in the element
of grey here they wanted it to be black
and white so it would be easier to make
the decisions in replay and on the field
so I don't think I changed the rule look
at we're just talking about a couple of
plays maybe just you know one or two
plays per weekend they get people
perplexed so III might change it to try
to make it more you know bring common
sense more into it but then again as I
say that then I don't have the answer I
wouldn't know
what to do to change it he's Mike
Pereira Fox Sports NFL rules analyst and
former vice president of officiating
very much okay a couple other plays here
explain to me the butt cheeks in the
Carolina game because what it does one
butt cheek equal two feet yeah you know
that's it it's one cheek equals two feet
I mean it's the old john madden thing
you know of one knee equals two feet
well one anything equals two feet except
a hand I mean the hand doesn't equal two
feet but an elbow equals two feet a
single butt cheek you know and and the
difference is like you know you have
what they call the heel toe on the
sidelines if it's a natural step and you
get the heel down first and then the toe
lands out-of-bounds it's incomplete you
have to get the whole foot inbounds but
you don't have to get the whole butt
down inbounds you just have to get one
cheek and so you don't have to press
flesh all the way on the ground for it
to be a catch it's just that first touch
of a cheek here we are grown men talking
about this I know gene starett or with
the index card measuring for the first
down do other like does everybody have
an index card to slide it down to see if
the football and is gonna touch the the
first down marker well you don't you you
have a card but not for that reason
every official has a card that they
record the penalties that they call on
the field you know they write down Oh
h76 if they call holding they they have
to record the timeouts on a card so you
all have a card and that's an old trick
there towards an old dog a little bit
Mike Keith wife folded why not just
slide the index card down
you know without folding it over well
you know it's interesting because in his
pool report after the game you know he
actually said that he had already
decided that it was a first down and he
was just using the card you know to
validate the decision that he already
made which to me is a little bit
nonsensical I've done it when I was a
referee I
but it was only when I couldn't tell I
actually didn't see him fold it to tell
you the truth and I think he did and I I
I didn't see but nothing jeans territory
doesn't surprise me he's the ultimate
he's the ultimate showman he looks good
he looks confident and you know when he
gets that television time whether it's
at a college basketball game or an NFL
football game he is going to get the
most out of the camera and Hockey League
gets the most out of the camera when he
talks Jean gets the most out of the
camera when he just poses and looks and
and makes his a signals all right he
explained this to see illegal touching
first of all I don't like that how that
is designated but it's called the
illegal touching Brandon cooks gets
penalized because there's the illegal
touching he didn't do the touching it's
the defensive back that did the touching
yeah it's a it's a it's an interesting
subject which they it's kind of a
ridiculous penalty to tell you the truth
you out of bounds Mike and then it's to
my benefit as a defensive player correct
and and even even though and it's a
different rule in college in the NFL
even though you're forced out of bounds
you can't come back and be the first to
touch unless you're fouled out of bounds
so if they too called illegal contact
for example and then that illegal
contact force them out of bounds and
then you'd come back in then you can if
you immediately come back in and
reestablish you can't make the catch but
it's kind of one of those silly
penalties there's no yardage associated
with it it's just an incomplete pass but
you know it's another thing about rules
that I don't like and and that's that
that play in college is a catch and and
you get the you get the game and in the
NFL it's not it's an illegal touch I I
would love to see more uniformity in
terms of the rules they're they're
complicated enough yeah and so if we
could somehow make them more alike on
Saturdays and Sundays we'd all benefit
and that includes the officials who come
from college and it takes an adjustment
period of of the different rules when
they get to the NFL you know since
they've been doing college for probably
10 15 years before they get there
it's confusing here Mike you're I just
exasperated you didn't yeah I'm sorry
yeah I get it
I get it it's just that you know was
talking you know for text messages to
the Joe Buck you know last night and it
had to do with the fumble play over the
incomplete pass in Pittsburgh and the
butt cheek play in our game and it's
just and this is Joe's point it's just
become too technical yeah and it's
almost not fun for fans or announcers to
watch I mean I get Jim Nantz and Tony
Romo I mean that was a strange play and
they finally picked up on it at the end
before the announcement was made but
this game probably because of all the
technology has gotten too technical and
and it becomes I agree with this it
becomes harder to watch but all George
Young I mean god bless him before he
passed away he was the at one point he
was the head of football operations at
the NFL and he was there and 999 in that
role when we brought replay back and and
he had a manila folder and instead of on
the tab writing instant replay as we
explored putting this back in he wrote
in huge letters he wrote the monster
roll and underlined it and you know what
he's right he's he's right this has
really changed the game and I'm not sure
it has changed it for the better
Mike enjoy your Monday I shall thank you
Mike that's Mike prayer Fox Sports NFL
rules analyst former vice president of
officiating it's exhausting for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you